welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of The Last
of Us episode four please hold my hand
which proves Ozark right that only the
worst people come from Kansas City
Missouri hey I'm not saying that
Prestige TV is let's break down all the
Easter eggs references to the games and
interesting details that you might have
missed and please subscribe to new
Rockstar's new channel the Deep dive
launching February 17th with a slate of
more investigatory analyzes of titles
you love like everything everywhere all
at once also this shirt is our last of
us inspired look for the light shirts
that you can get at nerd riot.shop we
opened on Ellie in the bathroom aiming
the pistol that she got from Frank's
drawer at the mirror like she's Travis
Bickle and Taxi Driver this gun is a
Beretta 70 series lightweight pistol
which the game developers modeled
Ellie's gun on but she cuddles this gun
she's not completely clueless but she's
romanticizing the weapon and not really
treating it with the respect that she
should like Travis Bickle Ellie is more
concerned with her appearance as a
hardened killer than the actual weight
of that responsibility also notice she
is in the men's bathroom here she's
fully masculinizing herself now I'm not
going to waste your time with some
mirrors our portals high school English
[__] because you know not every
mirror and every TV show or movie means
the same thing literary symbols are only
important to the context in which
they're presented in this context it's
more interesting to talk about the
Practical purpose of mirrors because
mirrors are one of many luxuries this
world has less of now remember Ellie
toyed with the truck side view mirror to
find Joel eyeing her in the reflection
last episode and it's really the mirror
and Ellie's reflection in it with the
gun that is more of Ellie's Fascination
than wielding the gun itself while Ellie
also acquired from Bill and Frank her
iconic red shirt from the games the
green plaid shirt that Joel changed into
after his shower was actually the same
shirt Frank wore on the day of his and
Bill's argument in episode three Joel is
siphoning some gas nice how does that
work it's a siphon
it's when liquid
travels Against Gravity because pressure
you don't know I know it works I have an
example of
standing air pressure the front door and
Bill's house slammed on its own because
Bill had left the bedroom window open
but actually Joel siphoning gas is a nod
to bill in the game Who tosses him a
siphon and says that you'd be amazed how
many cars still got gas in them Ellie
reads from will Livingston's no pun
intended Volume 2 which is one of
Ellie's belongings in the games it's one
of the things that you cannot open
yourself but alien cutscenes does read
from it the cover here is the same cover
from the game with the cows saying oh no
not an under one and then a duck saying
these puns quack me up the one that she
reads it doesn't matter how much you
push the envelope it'll still be
stationary it's actually the first one
she reads in the game it doesn't matter
how much you push the envelope it'll
still be stationary what is that joke
book no pun intended Volume 2 by Will
Livingston there's also some pretty
precise accuracy to the game with the
gay porn magazine that Ellie finds which
is the exact same Bearskin cover same
model pose same text men of the den
college hotties Ace fun champ and Ellie
making the same jokes even walk around
with that thing please get rid of it
close your horses I want to see what all
the fuss is about why are all these
Pages stuck together uh
whoa
how how the hell would he even walk
around with that thing get rid of that
hold your horses I want to see what all
the fuss is about why are these all
stuck together
um I'm just [__] with you now in the
game when Ellie tosses out the magazine
it lands in front of a Pittsburgh sign
but because this episode takes us Beyond
Pittsburgh there is no sign the cassette
tape that Ellie finds that's before
Joel's time is in the game Hank Williams
I'll never get out of this world alive
but here it's Hank Williams alone and
forsaken which is a darker folk song
about finding love in the summertime
just for that love to leave him by the
fall and the chorus of the song is a
prayer oh Lord if you hear me please
hold to my hand oh please understand
hold to my hand the inspiration for this
episode's title of please hold my hand
but in this case the woman who left us
here is really the America that we once
knew and the fact that it left us though
not the worst thing the amusement park
they pass is actually Worlds of Fun near
Kansas City Missouri and that roller
coaster is the Mamba a ride that opened
in 1998. the roller coasters made a
steal explaining why it would still be
intact mostly they drive past some bison
in the westward expansion across the
United States with the railroad in the
19th century many species of Bison were
hunted to extinction by passing train
Travelers shooting them for sport but
here we now see bison hurting peacefully
by the highway they also pass in Orbeez
recalling Frank's comeback last episode
and this is not an Arby's well Arvest
didn't have free lunch was a restaurant
did they pass this collapsed train
bridge this is an actual bridge and let
bridge Alberta and notice how a train
stretches across it a car dangling off
now if the world shut down not too long
after outbreak day that probably would
have been too soon for the bridge to
corrode naturally and collapse on its
own so either this train was warmed back
up years after outbreak day and the
bridge then collapsed or maybe the
government bombed this bridge to stop
this train from reaching a nearby City
they pull off the road to sleep in the
woods with no campfire to avoid being
spotted by people as this series in this
episode is adding to the danger of
infected the danger of humanity so what
are they gonna do Rob us well they'll
have way more and more than that
okay now Joel tells her this to give a
Stern warning to not wander but later as
they try to sleep she brings it up again
those people he said
there's no way anyone knows we're here
right
No One's Gonna find us
No One's Gonna find us so Joel regrets
scaring her and so he stays up all night
to keep a lookout with his rifle he's
doing for her what we assume builds it
for many nights for Frank letting his
partner sleep while he keeps watch
that's why the coffee the next morning
is so essential for Joel Ellie crawls
over to it cocooned and Frank's sleeping
bag episode 2 depicted her in a larval
Beetle stage as a butterfly flapped over
her head and now she's in the Cocoon
phase of her metamorphosis now Ellie's
road map has a red marking for an area
east of Pittsburgh which again is
supposed to be the next stop in the game
but here on the show they bypass it 76
West and then
70 West for like ever I-70 does go
forever from Western Pennsylvania to
Columbus to Indianapolis to St Louis
then to Kansas City Joel Recaps what
happened with Tommy how Tommy was a
joiner who enlisted dividing Desert
Storm and then after the outbreak formed
a crew that moved to Boston and joined
up with Tess and that worked until Tommy
met Marlene and enjoying the fireflies
and then quit the fireflies and moved to
Wyoming Ellie asks if you don't think
there's hope for the world why bother
going on I mean you gotta try right you
haven't seen the world so you don't know
keep going for family
that's about it I'm not family no your
cargo
but I made a promise to Tess she was
like family I think Joel secretly by now
sees Ellie as more than cargo but he
doesn't want her treating him like a
father yet Ellie claims she's a tired
but we jump cut to her out like a light
as they pull up to Kansas City now
Pittsburgh to KC is a 13-hour Drive
which would be more if they have to stop
every hour for gas I don't know maybe
it's late enough in the year for the
days to be really long and when they
arrive to Kansas City it's late
afternoon but we know this is one day
because later Ellie says it's her second
day in a car so Joe must have been
flooring it the whole way either way our
man is exhausted the tunnel to Kansas
City is blocked by Us Sarah Lee bread
truck damn flower always ruining
everything and one of the cars is a
burnt quartz inside so these drivers
might have been torched to prevent
potential infected from getting in the
city they get lost in the city it's a
highway I can't tell from this I'm all
turned around don't look at the state
map look at the inside either ah since
Kansas City is on the border of two
states Missouri and Kansas Ellie would
really need to look at a scaled-in city
map not a state map now they passed a
cinema playing matched Stickman and
underworld both of which released in the
month of September 2003 and yes that is
the Globe Theater of Calgary in Alberta
Canada where they shot a lot of these
outdoor scenes now in an alley is a
burnt pile of corpses and you can
actually see their skulls intact which
Joel explained last episode means that
these people were killed without being
infected which is bad news they find the
qz vacated though and Joel immediately
sees it's a trap
are we gonna help him no
as we saw in the pilot episode Joel does
not stop for anyone later he tells Ellie
how he knew he was a trap I've been on
both sides
it was a long time ago we did what we
needed to survive that explains why Joel
doesn't pass any moral judgment on these
people he doesn't really take anything
personally they do take things
personally and that's why Joel is able
to execute here he's all business they
crash into a laundromat where they get
holed up by gunfire they're not going to
hit you look at me
they're not gonna hit you yeah pretty
confident words considering everything
is exploding around them but Joel called
his shots earlier this episode what if
you don't find him oh well how do you
know I'm persistent so Joel takes out
one of the hunters which catches the
other by surprise
you [__] I like that we hear
these hunters in the background but we
never cut to them in close up reflecting
the experience playing the game where we
stay with Joel's point of view and have
to listen all these NPCs cussing you out
taking care of yourself is important so
good thing geology makes it easy to do
geology is a 16-time award-winning
personalized skincare company recognized
in hypebeast birdie Men's Health Esquire
and ask men grooming Awards with over 6
000 5 Star reviews just take a quick 30
second diagnostic quiz and geology will
create a simple and effective skin care
or hair care routine customized just for
you with ingredients that are
dermatologist tested proven to work and
personalize to your needs for skin care
geology's got strengthening shampoo and
conditioner and co-wash which will
transform your routine and deliver the
best hair of your life it extends the
time between washes and replaces the
need for so many products so you wash
your hair less and save money more they
also offer body washes and deodorants
that are free of harsh ingredients and
smell great for skincare they be covered
from all angles you can fight acne
reduce oilness prevent wrinkles combat
dark or puffy under eyes have smoother
hydrated skin and Target signs of aging
their daily personalized skincare
routine comes with Too Faced washes a
morning face cream a retinol night cream
and eye cream and right now for a
limited time you can get a five piece
trial set for only 15 if you use code
Rockstar's 70 at checkout it's over 150
a product for just 15 on top of that
you'll get an additional bonus offer on
one of their brand new skin hair and
body products of your choice when you
add it to your trial to get started just
click the link in the description the
younger hunter gets a drop on Joel
yeah we really get a sense of the Rage
of these Hunters they aren't NPCs
they're people who are reacting to Joel
killing their friends and relatives and
Ellie shoots this kid but it's not
really like the moment from the game
where La uses her gun the first time to
shoot that guy off Joel when he tries to
drown him in the Hotel this is a much
more sadder more human moment we don't
even see the bullet hit we only know
from the kid's bloody hand that she got
him in the butt and he panics
okay it's okay it's over we're not
fighting anymore I'm gonna go home I'll
tell everyone you're good I don't know
yeah this isn't a Walking Dead savior
who's evil to The Bitter End this is
more like melish's heartbreaking death
and Saving Private Ryan this kid is
begging for his life and he tells him
his name to try to make himself harder
to kill which is one of the first things
Frank did when he met bill
first my name's Frank upright
what's your name but it doesn't work and
Joel kills Brian but not with Ellie's
Beretta but with a knife but actually
learning Brian's name gives us more info
later when the other Hunters arrive
foreign
from here we cut to a former federal
prison facility where there are bullet
holes and blood stains on the walls
showing us that this place was taken by
force the Hunter's leader is Kathleen
Melanie Linsky a new character created
for the HBO series she interrogates his
doctor the bird quests hmm
no
Mark Anthony Halpin Carrie Schreiber
haven't seen them the chance Henry
Burrell Mark Anthony Halpin is actually
a nod to Craig Mason's friend and a
known Puzzle Master Mark Halpin Craig
Mason is a huge hobbyist when it comes
to puzzles and things like that a list
of names reminds us of Hans Landa's
interrogation at the beginning of
Inglorious Bastards when he lists the
names of Jewish families who went into
hiding this is often what happens when a
new military force violently takes over
and wants to root out all the families
they deem disloyal to the new regime but
as Kathleen reads the federal rights
board medical attention family visit
food and clothing she reveals these as
false promises from an old guard that
she suffered under I wonder if this is
so
where my brother was beaten to death the
doctor tries to clean his hands of all
these war crimes it has to stop
stop now we now I know I just compared
Kathleen to a Nazi character she's also
similar to a mossadi agent hunting down
doctors who work for the Nazis She Wants
Revenge all the evil that hurt her loved
ones to never be able to hurt anyone
ever again and that includes guilt by
association so she wants to find Henry
whom she believes ratted on her brother
to Pedra and a doctor won't tell her
where Henry is he thinks she's bluffing
I'm your doctor but the hunters bring
back the people Joel wounded and killed
and we see that he stabbed Brian in the
chest and arguably more merciful wound
than I guess cutting his throat at least
this gets to be an open casket Kathleen
asks will he live what if I had a doctor
I'm sorry and I love this moment
immediately if you see Kathleen go back
and shoot the doctor she wasn't asking
with hope that she might save these
wounded she was asking to make sure she
had no further excuse to keep that
doctor alive Kathleen is not thinking
about the long-term health of this
community in her mind they are facing a
more short-term threat and she's more
focused on Revenge Kathleen links these
Hunter's death with Henry speculating
that Henry radio Joel in and she uses
this to justify sending the hunters out
to the homes of every collaborator to
kill them this is a pretty big logical
leap and it's crazy that it works it
just shows how afraid and how nuts these
people are that's the American way folks
notice how their trucks were former
fedra but the logos have been crossed
out so this group overthrew fedra these
are Hunters that we meet in Pittsburgh
in the game and this group is not
fireflies they actually turned against
the fireflies too after they overthrew
fedra on the newspaper Joel peeks out
through there's a headline about Powell
presumably referring to Colin Powell who
is Secretary of State in 2003 and made a
lot of headlines for his human testimony
when the US invaded Iraq earlier that
year there's actually another one by hi
to Ellie with the headline Iraq cost 3.9
billion a month huh you know the way
bush used 911 to invade Iraq is kind of
like how Kathleen uses Joel killing a
few Hunters to wipe out all the
political enemies in Kansas City despite
these two things actually being
unrelated it's human nature folks Joel
struggles to debrief with Ellie after
the situation with Brian I know what
it's like
first time that you hurt someone like
that if you uh I'm not good at this yeah
you really aren't Joel apologizes saying
that Ellie shouldn't have had to shoot
him Ellie cries but she reveals why it
wasn't my first time yeah Ellie isn't
crying ever shooting Brian she's crying
over some past person that she hurt Joel
teaches Ellie how to hold the gun with
two hands thumbs and you're locked which
makes it harder for her to drop the gun
when it recoils or if someone were to
try to grab it now Kathleen's Lieutenant
is Perry played by Jeffrey Pierce who
plays Tommy in the games Jeffrey Pierce
actually said in the behind the episode
feature that Perry has a past in the
military making me wonder if he was a
former bed dress soldier who turned on
the rest of bedra and helped Kathleen
overthrow them maybe he was a witness to
Kathleen's brother getting beaten to
death he takes her to Henry and Sam's
hideout with Sans drawings of a
superhero on the walls both Henry and
Sam are actually drawn as superheroes
and notice as Kathleen first enters this
addict one of the superheroes foes is a
federal soldier in blue uniform and riot
gear so really Henry and Sam's enemies
are the same as Kathleen's enemies Perry
then shows her this caved in room with
floor that pulsates from beneath
presumably some Infected blow I'm gonna
talk more about what's going on here in
spoiler Corner after climbing 33 floors
Jill spread some broken glass I don't
want someone sneaking up on us while
we're sleeping oh I get it crunch crunch
crunch you sure you're gonna hear it of
course I'll hear it that's the damn
point again this has all been one day
Joel got no sleep the night before
because he's Guardian Ellie he then
drove 13 hours then they crashed then he
had to shoot two guys and then he was
nearly strangled then he stabbed that
kid and then he climbed 33 flights our
man is 56 years old a bomb could go off
and it wouldn't wake him up after this
exhausting day but Joel asked Ellie
about the first time she heard someone
in Ellie for the first time doesn't want
to talk about something Ellie then
deflects saying Joel doesn't hear Too
Well out of his right ear but you know
that's also the side that was facing her
in the truck during their drive you
might have just been ignoring her but
Joel doesn't deny it he attributes it to
years of shooting on that side and
Ellie's diarrhea pun relaxes Joel enough
so that he can fall asleep and he is now
turned toward Ellie with his watch
Facing out his father-daughter
connection returning but Henry and Sam
have found them Sam perched on Joel with
a superhero mask painted on his face and
we end the episode with a gun in our
face reminding us of Ellie back in the
first scene putting a gun at the mirror
but in this instance Sam correctly has
both hands on the gun signaling to Joel
that this kid doesn't need him to teach
him how to kill okay on to spoiler
Corner let's talk about that cave-in
this likely was above the sewer which in
the Pittsburgh section of the game that
these episodes are relocating from is
where a group of survivors try to make
home but then they all get infected but
since the bill part of the game is where
you meet your first bloater and we
didn't see a bloater in episode 3. I am
guessing the trailer shot of the bloater
rising up from a hole in the ground
might be coming next episode and a
floater might be among the sewer Runners
and clickers that are gonna be crawling
up through this building but also
remember this series is suggesting that
the fungus's fibers grow deep beneath
the ground and snake through the soil
are all connected by a network based off
of the world's biggest organism being in
eastern Oregon a single fungus that
spans like four square miles so I think
the fibers of this fungus may have
helped tunnel beneath this ground to
free the infected underneath that's one
big patch of cordyceps all working
together to release more of these drones
we'll get to know Sam and Henry next
episode so there's no need to say too
much about them other than the show is
really connecting them more to these
Hunters that there's some history
between Henry and Kathleen whereas in
the game Henry and Sam arrive to
Pittsburgh after coming from Hartford
and don't really have that much of a
history with the hunters and of course
the question who did Ellie hurt well
Joel and Ellie's chat wasn't about
shooting someone is about hurting
someone so maybe Ellie might just be
alluding some Survivor skill over Riley
getting infected we know Riley's on her
mind the Mortal Kombat 2 game there's a
reference to Left Behind when Riley told
Ellie about an arcade game and of course
this joke book was a joke book given to
her by Riley and then remember back
earlier in the episode there was this
moment where Ellie looks up at the night
sky which could be setting up the moment
from part two of the game when Joel
takes Ellie to a space museum for her
birthday and gives her an audio of an
Apollo launch so that she can imagine
space travel this girl from considering
the truck a spaceship someday she will
be able to sit in a real space
spacecraft hey by the way I have been
wearing Joel's iconic flint and Tinder
wax canvas trucker jacket from huckberry
you can buy your own by clicking the
link in the description and that'll
support new Rockstar's Last of Us
coverage another reminder to subscribe
to the Deep dive you can follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at eavos follow
new rockstars And subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]